cent quarante trois satellites viennent
d'être mis en orbite le plus grand
nombre de satellites jamais envoyé en
une seule fois
parmi eux deux satellites du latmos dont
un sous pavillon français lui vécu ça tu
ici ce qui est un petit peu nouveau
c'est qu'effectivement on a on a tout
fait de a poussé une certaine fierté
parce que du coup cessé toutes les
équipes qui sont concernés tous les
laboratoires toute l'université nos
tutelles le cnrs nous deux universités
voilà qui nous ont aidés si le nano
satellites devaient initialement partir
le 16 décembre dernier les différents
reports dus aux conditions météo et
problèmes techniques n'ont pas inquiéter
l'équipe dès qu'il ya un petit problème
technique bas ces vérifications et on
attend leur feu vert pour lancer donc
non pour nous c'était c'était plutôt
bien ces retards par compte
effectivement une fois que là je le
faisais par là c'est là où la tension
est la plus grande parce que c'est là où
tout peut arriver pour notre santé la
fusée falcon nine a finalement décollé
ce dimanche depuis la base de lancement
de cap canaveral en floride
le lancement a lieu à 16 heures heure de
paris une heure plus tard le nano
satellites uvs q7 était en orbite
la mission a franchi les étapes
critiques on a déjà au démarrage la la
propulsion de la fusée mais on va un
moment atteindre un niveau de puissance
maximum donc entre 0 et 10 secondes
c'est le niveau le plus contraignant au
niveau des instruments lors de la mise
en orbite
alors une autre étape c'est l'état du
climat et là on était dans une situation
particulière où il y avait une certaine
vitesse de vent qui était supérieure à
20 km/heure donc ça peut créer du
cisaillement au niveau de la fusée
chacun des satellites a été éjecté
individuellement et mis en orbite avec
succès elle reste à savoir si le nano
satellites a survécu aux différentes
étapes pour nous aujourd'hui le plus
important c'est d'avoir la communication
le signe qu'il est vivant et donc on
attend un signal une émission ce
satellite pour voir qu'il est bien
vivant
un signal reçu dimanche soir confirmant
sa viabilité et la réussite de la
mission coût global de la mission 3
millions d'euros